it's lights out for Lori Chicago mayor
Lori Lightfoot suffering a humiliating
re-election defeat that should put
progressives everywhere on notice voters
kicking Lori to the curb after enduring
four years of her insane liberal crime
policies I guess folks got tired of
living in a crime-ridden nightmare where
you constantly have to dodge gunfire
even inside your own home and maybe
businesses didn't really like all their
stuff being looted in a smash and grab
we all know her atrocious track record
murder robbery theft all up big it seems
obvious to everybody why she lost but
she's blaming it on sexism and racism I
think she did a bang-up job
I'm grateful that we work together to
remove a record number of guns off our
streets we homicides and
the progress on Public Safety we fought
the right fights and we put this city on
a better path in the end you don't
always win every battle
but you never regret taking on the
powerful and bringing in the light
and if you're worried about her future
don't Lori has other skills to fall back
on
come on
baby don't you wanna go all right well
against my better judgment I'm going to
go to you first Jessica
tell us what this means for the
Democratic Party
well a Democrat is still going to be the
mayor of Chicago so it means that we
still have that right but you're about
to see which will be interesting in the
runoff kind of the battle for the soul
of the party right what's going on here
um with a more Conservative candidate
and the more Progressive candidate so
this isn't the end of progressivism in
Chicago at all so um Johnson who's a
more Progressive candidate is arguably
more Progressive than Lori Lightfoot
even is uh but he's probably not going
to win
he's probably not but there is this
interesting thing which I haven't seen
that much discussion of you know who is
going to get the Hispanic vote because
Garcia who's one of the candidates who
didn't make the runoff had majority of
the Hispanic vote in Chicago that is
huge and Johnson is the black candidate
we'll see what happens there basically
what happened there were six black
candidates in this and the vote got
split a lot and Johnson ended up getting
kind of the last minute surge in Black
support but you don't really know where
it's going to go because Volus is
pronouncing it correctly Dallas
um has the much tougher on crime set of
policies he's happy that he's the quote
enemy of the teachers union at this
point those are things that could
actually resonate with a lot of minority
voters so my assumption is and my people
uh Chicago local Chicago strategists are
saying that he will be the one who wins
this but it's going to be interesting to
watch kind of a more of a Joe manchin
let's say candidate play out against
more of an AOC candidate
um in the runoffs let's stomp on Lori's
political grave a little bit harder
judge okay thank you that's what I was
looking for yes her loss is a win for
the people of Chicago this is a woman
who didn't understand her constituents
who didn't understand that the first
order of government is the safety of its
people her policies damage Chicago
politically economically sociologically
I lived in Chicago for three years four
years I lived on Michigan Avenue and I
mean that City you don't even half the
businesses are closed there and now I
understand the clearance rates for
homicides is that 50 percent when the
truth is we've got DNA we've got phones
we've got I mean you look at the Murdoch
trial the whole case is circumstantial
which telephone records and all that
other stuff but you know even even her
personality the New York Times said that
she created feuds and all kinds of
insults uh against people and this is a
woman who for a time only wanted to
speak with black journalists okay I mean
and and it is I think a test of the
Democrats crime message and I think
that's why vallus is going to win we
picked him the other day
um you know when you say that you're
only going to talk to journalists of
color you know sure to think about
taking care of victims of color because
she didn't take care of victims of color
starting with the south side of Chicago
and she could have done that she has a
lot of power but her crime is up what
what is it murder rate 59 and she just
said that they cut back on the murder
rates or something bizarre like that and
let her sing and dance away to her next
job but she hasn't made anyone's life
safer or better good riddance a lot of
people very happy in the city of Chicago
today yeah I imagine and also I mean it
had been hard when de Blasio left office
because he was the worst mayor in
America right and she was the second
worst mayor in America and then she
became the worst mayor in America and
she fought
everybody she was always in a fight
every single day and there was no uh
humility there was never a moment of
let's try something different it was
just always just fighting with everybody
and then she says that this is because
uh the I guess the voters of Chicago are
sexist and racist but you can be an
African-American woman in politics as a
mayor of a big city and win re-election
Muriel Bowser did it in Washington D.C
and she did she got reelected by a huge
margin they also have crime problems
there Washington DC has got a lot of
problems but she got reelected Keisha
land's bottoms was the mayor of Atlanta
she decided not to run for a second term
but I bet she would have won as well
this is also interesting about how
people if they decide to make a change
they can Chessa Boudin getting recalled
in San Francisco is an example but then
you have something like Larry krasner in
Philadelphia where that doesn't work but
I I think there's been enough examples
that if people want to make a difference
you can do that and a lot of problems
have been from the liberal prosecutors
but progressivism in many of these
cities is leading them down a wrong path
this hopefully is a warning sign to
others yeah we've had a few of these
warning signs Greg oh I'm Gonna Miss Her
you are you brought me so much joy even
though she brought everyone else paying
that little garden gnome
uh uh but uh she says she lost because
she's a black woman and that she's being
held to a higher standard and apparently
that higher standard is competence
because she's she is she was a
historical first she was the first black
lesbian mayor of Chicago now she's
another historical first she's the worst
mayor that Chicago's ever had she will
go down in history a couple of times but
I don't what's interesting to me about
this is why is this news why are we so
relieved you know it's like somebody
somebody who is the worst mayor in the
country it should have been a foregone
conclusion that she was going to lose
but we didn't really know because it was
a sense of ambivalence about about this
sort of progressivism that like she is
bulletproof left wing black female
lesbian made her immune to criticism
there was nothing you could do like
people were complaining about her
forever and that was where her arrogance
came from she knew that if you went
after her she would come after you with
a rant that accused you of being a
homophobic racist so that imperviousness
allowed her to kind of basically do
whatever she wanted get in all these
feuds completely ignore the suffering of
her constituents because she knew that
she had a moat she had a moat the same
way Don Lemon had a moat right awoke
moat oh that's beautiful but it's a
lesson like you shouldn't be picking
your politicians or are based on what on
What box they tick or if they look like
you you owe them nothing you owe them
nothing especially when they expect that
privilege from you while they destroy a
city it's like I hope people are like
you know what it doesn't matter what
skin color they are who they sleep with
you know if they're going to make your
cities safer vote for them
and she did just the opposite she said
you cops can't chase suspects it's like
you know if you lose them just let them
go it's all right yeah we have lost a
few good ones we've got Cuomo and Laurie
you know what the wicked she could do
the eight o'clock hour on CNN right
problem solved yes I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now